[Beats x3]
Did you see the teaser for Deadpool 2 that came out, before Logan?
It was a perfect, Deadpool story, hilarious, shocking and er..
Wait a minute
How did he eat that ice cream, he doesn't have a spoon?
You can break the fourth wall all you want, Wade.
But don't you for a second try to tell me you eat your ice cream spoon-less.
Unless...
[Overlay] there is no spoon
There's no spoon! Deadpool exists within the matrix.
I call this one
THEORY CONFIRMED!
[Intro Music]
Hello Internet, and welcome to Film Theory
The show that is so poor we don't even have a fourth wall to break.
This week I am revisiting Deadpool, because
if I am being 100% honest, I couldn't for the life of me think of any good theories for Guardians of the Galaxy.
Seriously! I love that movie. I just had like writers blocked or something. Groot's speech impediment, that's
Kinda boring. Uhh, who's Peter dad, which is going to get revealed in Guardians 2, like science of
rocket raccoon...that's not fun either.
Anyways, if you have any good idea for guardians, let me know down in the comments. I want to do a video on the franchise so bad
But hey, you know what that's okay because it gives me an excuse to spend a little bit more quality time with everyone favorite merc with a mouth
Wade Wilson
Last year Deadpool movie gave us all the violent comedy that we could ask for
But despite all the cool action scenes, holiday themed sexy time, the thing everyone loves about this character is his metaness.
The fact that he talks to us.
[Wade fucking Wilson] Fourth wall break inside a fourth wall break that's like 16 walls.
He is like the super hero equivalent to a YouTube vlogger.
All he needs to do is ask for people to Subscribe and get himself a LootCrate sponsorship and he has made it
Liza Koshy
You watch your back, Deadpool's coming for ya!
Now, during the film he breaks the 4th wall exactly 23 times
To make sure that we're having a good time
But what I'm out to prove today is that
Deadpool's most meta joke is the ultimate of wall breaks
A 24th, wink at the camera that skirted under all of our collective radars
A move so brilliant, so subversive, and so purely Deadpool
That it can only be accomplished in a movie like this one
So my loyal theorists, today I ask you to consider the following
Did Deadpool, write Deadpool?
Obviously the movie had real writers credited to Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick
But did they write the movie to be as though Deadpool
Wrote the movie
Creating a script that is in it of itself a 4th wall break
A script written by it's own character about himself starring himself
it's a premise that seems absurd
But then again, absurdity is exactly what this movie, and its character
Are all about
Let's start at the beginning
Deadpool is clearly aware of his role as a movie character
And the film in general
And as we see in the opening moment
He's really pleased to finally have a movie all of his own
[Deadpool] Who's balls did I have to fondle to get my own movie?
But that's not always the case
In fact, Deadpool has a...
Difficult history
With adaptation of his story
As an example
Let's look at Deadpool video game from back in 2013
The opening scene of the game
Shows us Deadpool on a phone with the game developer
Talking about an idea that he pitched to them
His name for it,
The most awesome game ever
But when High Moon Studio refused to greenlight that pitch
He rigs their studio with explosives and forces them to make the game for him
Fast forward a bit and we see that Deadpool is worried about of all things
The script
And when he finally gets his script delivered to his door
He ABSOLUTELY hates it
So
He takes it upon himself to rewrite the whole thing in crayon
And he doesn't just stop at the script
We watch as he call up voice actor
Nolan North
and hires him for the job of playing himself
In the game that we in that moment are playing
So writers of Deadpool's stories have clearly shown a history of his character
Hijacking productions about himself and rewriting them
But that's not all
In the comics
Deadpool has never been shy about talking directly to the
writer or artist of any given issue
Take for instance
Deadpool Volume 1 where he address creator Rob Liefeld directly
So why does he never do that in the movie?
Sure he moves the camera to force the audience to look away from him torturing "Agent Smith"
But other than that he never directly interacts with the people making the film
Director, sound guy, or writer
Instead he only complains about the studio
The one's paying for the movie
Doing things like complaining that the studio was too cheap to get more than two X-Men for their film
But as for the creative team
Outside of getting ripped on the opening credits he leaves them completely alone
Which is a strange  decision for a character who does this literally
ALL THE TIME
in all his other incarnations
Even in moments when that team supposedly screws up
*awkward fapping*
Lets focus on this moment for a second think about it this way
His 4th wall breaks don't stop the action of the movie
In his opening monologue, we see cars driving pass him as he sits on the edge of the highway addressing us
He even mentions directly to Colossus a few minutes later that these 4th wall breaks are specifically for our benefit
These moment show us that outside of the flash backs
The 4th wall breaks are happening in the moment
In real time, when he adjust the camera before of his torture of "Agent Smith"
Smith look directly at the camera before it turns away
This proofs that Deadpool is manipulating the 4th wall in these moments as they're being filmed
As they happened
Not after the fact or pausing the action to step out of the events of the movie
And yet, when he's caught having special time with his unicorn
He doesn't yell or complain to the editors or the director that they're filming this
In fact, he knows it's being left in the final product of the movie
Acknowledging this was a part that we weren't meant to see
But that we're seeing it anyway
But if he's adhering to the rules of his 4th wall breaks as it's been established as they're happening in real time
He wouldn't know this was being left in the final cut
So, long story short
Even thou Deadpool says we weren't meant to see it the fact that he comments on the fact we weren't meant to see it
Shows that he knows that we're seeing it
And that he has approved that the fact we are seeing it
Thus, he's in control of how this story is being told
*mind blown*
WHoOoOohohoho
You got all that?
Ohh it's like a logic puzzle!
I think I..just felt my brain melt through my ear carnal
Alright, so this is the Deadpool origin story as Deadpool would want us to see it
Clearly he would wanna make himself look as good as possible right?
Right! and that's exactly what he does
In the comics, Deadpool's history often left vague
The main thing about his origin always tend to remain constant though are
A. he's a mercenary before his mutation
B. he's Canadian
And C. his superpower comes from Wolverine's blood
Now, Deadpool references Wolverine and Hugh Jackman multiple times throughout the movie
BUTT
The movie never mentioned any other mutant
Wolverine or otherwise having anything to do with Deadpool's mutation
In this version of events, the mutation was inside him all along
It's unlocked through lots of torture
This makes Deadpool the star of his own story
And not some background character who got his powers riding the coattail some other mutant
It makes Deadpool inherently special rather than having to get his specialness bestowed upon him
By someone else
Speaking of those mutation in both the comics and the film
Deadpool's only true mutation is the ability to heal wounds really fast
Doing things like cutting off and regrowing his hand *BABY HAAAANDS!!!*
But, other than that he's a completely normal human being
Which makes some of the things he does in the film a bit far-fetched
Even by comic book movies standards
Sure, they reference his special forces training
But for as stellar as spec-ops training maybe
I doubt it gives someone the ability to line up a triple headshot while flipping through the air
Soldiers tend to keep their feet on the ground whenever possible
They ain't training you to be an acrobat
Also for taking the film at face value Deadpool would be at fluent at soccer
Firing blind
Sword throwing
In the comics Deadpool was able to do thing like this by using his 4th wall breaking
He reads ahead, jumps between panels, allowing him to do cool stunts and moves like these
But the film version of Deadpool never uses the 4th wall breaking for his own advantage
When in combat he remains within the world of the film even if he occasionally strikes a silly pose mid flight
So where did the cirque du soleil murder ability come from?
Our only option is that, whoever wrote this
Really wanted Deadpool to come off looking as cool as possible in the final film
Even if he might not really have those abilities based on his mutation
And who would wanna make Deadpool looked like the coolest superhero of all time more than Deadpool himself
From around the subject of looking good
Wade Wilson REALLY cares about his appearance
So much so that he completely avoids talking to the love of his life
Simply because he turn into the human equivalent to the California raisin
Deadpool clearly loves the look of Ryan Renolds almost as much as he loves stuffed unicorns
And if Deadpool choose any actor to play him, it would be Ryan
We know this because he thought of himself this way for years
In Cable & Deadpool volume 1 number 2, Deadpool refers to himself as quote
"Ryan Renolds crossed with a shar-pei"
And if you think that's just tongue and cheek movie references is worth noting that this issue was from 2004
5 years before Ryan Renolds played Deadpool in X-Men Origins
And more than a decade before Ryan Renolds play Deadpool in the good Deadpool movie
And remember how in the game we saw Deadpool cast Nolan North for his voice
Well, in a film, it'd be total wish fulfillment for Deadpool the character to cast the role of himself
As the world sexiest Canadian
However, the part of the film that feels most like Deadpool's writer wish fulfillment
Is Wade's relationship with Vanessa
She does appears in the comics, but her story is completely different there
The big difference is that they never get back together
I'm not kidding!
Deadpool's epic quest to reclaim his lost love is completely unique to the film
In the comic, she's discovered to be a shapeshifting mutant
Who also become a mercenary after he leaves her
In the film, this relationship is changed from the brief fling, to a love story for the ages
Complete with the perfect Hollywood ending
And as we see throughout Deadpool
Wade, just love himself some romantic movie cheese
*reference no. 1*
*aaaaand another reference*
Even the physics of the movie is rewritten so that Deadpool can gives himself his desired happy ending
Ajax has Vanessa in a suffocation chamber made out of glass and metal
Now earlier in the movie we saw Wade Wilson escape an identical chamber by launching it across the room with an explosion
Which, as you see here shattered the glass
And yet, when Vanessa is in the exact replica of that chamber
She falls of an aircraft carrier and gets buried in huge slabs of concrete
All after Deadpool has already crack the glass to help her breath
So, of course, she emerges without a scratch on her *sarcasm*
WHAT?
COME ON!
Look at the size of that concrete slab!
As much as I love doing unnecessary math on this show
I don't think I need to crunch any numbers to know that
That glass is not gonna be in one piece when she hits the ground
And I'm not even gonna address the fact that Vanessa survived the fall to begin with
More convenient rewrite by the guy in the red and black spandex
At this point you might be thinking to yourself
Hang on Matt Patt, this is all possible
But it can also be a load of confirmation bias
And yeah, you're right
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT!
But there is one last minor detail that I think brings it all together
When "Agent Smith" shows up to recruit Deadpool for the superhero creation program
Just listen to what Wade's best buddy Weasel says
"That guy over there came in looking for you"
"little Grim Reaper type I don't know...might further the "PLOT"
But, hold on
Since when can he break the 4th wall?
Until this very moment, no one else seems aware that they're in a movie
The only way this line makes any sort of senses
is if Weasel knows that "Agent Smith is there to literally further a movie's plot
No one would naturally say this
But it is the sort of logical inconsistency that Deadpool himself would write into a script
And that brings us all the way back around to the opening credit of the film
Each crew and cast member gets themselves a sarcastic description
Directed by an overpaid tool, produced by asshats
Starring a hot chick, a CGI character, a gratuitous cameo
Of all the titles, the only complimentary ones are for Deadpool himself
As God's perfect idiot
And you guess it, the writers
AKA the real heroes
Could it be that Wade Wilson is trying to slip us a little hint as that who he thinks is really to thank
For the spectacle you're about to see
But hey, that's just a theory
A FILM THEORY!
Aaaaaaaaand
CUT!
*enter some kind of I don't know type of music*
*it's like a fucking carnival music type of shit*
*Oh God how long will this music last...*
*please send help*
*aaaaaaand it's done! finally!*